[Music]
hello everyone
so we'll continue with uh where we left
off last time
so we had we obtained this
particular formula
and we'll rewrite it here
and discuss a very few important things
in connection with this so first of all
let me just state that this very
important formula was
derived by koshi by
[Music]
a mathematician named hoshi
and in his honor it is referred to as
bush's formula or porsche's relation or
koshi's law
or porsche stress theorem sometimes okay
uh various names for it but all bearing
the name of the great mathematician
the cautious formula relation
or stress theorem
okay now
this was in index notation now what you
would like to write this
as uh in in vector or compact notation
so there
we have to write it in this fashion
so what what is very important to note
here
is that is the presence of the transpose
here
okay so this is sigma j i n j
uh correspondingly in the in that the
vector or compact notation
uh this transpose will come and you can
actually verify this
by noting that the stress
the stress tensor itself its equivalent
matrix representation
will be sigma 1 1 sigma 1 2
sigma 1 3 sigma
2 1 sigma 2 2 sigma
2 3 sigma
a1 sigma 32 sigma 33
and you can actually quickly check this
that
because in the earlier slide as you can
see
these things were like sigma 1 1 sigma 2
1 n2 plus sigma 3 1 and 3
that is why you first need to take a
transpose of this and then multiply with
this
with this n hat okay uh
so uh suppose the equivalent matrix
representation of this would be
very simply
so all of this uh they're referred to as
the coaches formula or law or relation
or stress theorem
now uh it is very important to note uh
so all this is about the maths but it is
very important to note and i'm sure
almost all of you know about this but it
is so very important that i'd like to
still emphasize it
so what is the physical significance or
what
what is it actually denoted by each of
these press components okay so suppose
suppose we we consider a
a cuboid like this
and let's say our x1 is in this
direction
x2 is in this direction and
the x3 is in this direction
okay so the stress component
sigma 1 1 this one
will be like this please do not think of
it like a force vector okay this is
simply a visual representation of
the stress component okay
so this will be sigma 1 1
the sigma 1 2 will be like this
this will be sigma 1 2
let me just draw it such that both the
indices are clearly visible
sigma 1 2 and the sigma 1 3
will be like this now you note that
whenever we are writing like sigma
1 to this first
index this first index
1 it is
denoting the unit outward normal
to the plane under consideration so here
our plane under consideration is this
plane
and it is perpendicular to the x1 axis
so this first index it represents
the unit the direction of the unit
outward normal
to the plane under consideration the
second index
it represents the direction along which
the stress component is being considered
so for sigma 1 2 which is like this
the second index it is this second index
which is representing the direction
along this so you note
that this direction is oriented along x2
okay similarly for sigma 1 3 the first
index one is representing
the unit outward normal to the plane on
which this stress component is being
taken
so even though this sigma 1 3 is like
this oriented along x 3
but that direction is represented by the
second index
the first index represents the unit
outward normal to the plane under
consideration so
so we should be very very clear about
that similarly if we consider
this plane this top plane
this will be what sigma 2 2
and what will be sigma 2 1 sigma 2 1
will be the stress component like this
which is the first index is given by 2
because the unit outward normal is along
the x 2 direction
and since the direction of the stress
component itself is along the one
direction
so the second component is like that
similarly this will be sigma 2 3
and finally this one will be
sigma 3 3 this
will be what sigma 3
2 and this will be
sigma 3 1
okay now uh suppose
we want to consider what is happening on
that plane the on the other hidden plane
okay
so let me write so let me draw that
separately
let me draw that separately here so this
is that plane
which is hidden behind on the left hand
side
so for that the unit outward normal to
that
is along the negative one direction so
it is along the negative one direction
okay so uh even though
none of the textbooks will write like
this but
when when i am teaching my students i
always like to point it out
that you try to think of it like this
you place two
two blank spaces here and then you write
the direction properly like
it is along the minus one direction you
write like minus one
okay so this minus one represents the
unit outward normal to the plane under
consideration
it is certainly not along the one
direction it is parallel to the one
direction but opposite
in sense so this minus sign represents
the opposite instance
and the stress component itself is
opposite
so this is minus one so together this
minus and minus it is like a
plus kind of thing so so nobody
okay please do not write like this this
is only for the sake of visual
understanding
so we still write this as sigma 1 1 so
let me erase this part out
okay we never ever write like this it is
only for the sake of
understanding that i wrote like this
so this is very much sigma 1 1.
now you think about sigma and the other
the shear
or the other two components which are
lying along the plane so
should it be oriented along like this
or like this okay now in order to
preserve the positivity convention
what we say is that
on this one
it will be like this and why is it so
well you see
let me just first put it down the first
index is definitely 1
and the second index will be 2 but what
is really going on here
first index so again going by our visual
understanding let me
put two blank spaces here the first one
is minus 1
because you understand the unit outward
normal to this plane is along the minus
1 direction
okay now we have to maintain some kind
of positivity convention positivity
convention means
nothing there should not be negative
sign in front of these indices
okay so that is what is meant by that uh
so if you just put a 2
okay if you just put a 2 here then it
will you will end up with a sigma
of minus 1 2. now that is that is
completely ridiculous okay
we don't ever write like that it has it
has no meaning uh
so but i'm i just want to illustrate you
what is happening
uh how it how it is so first of all you
know that this is violating the
positivity convention positive means
it should not come with a negative sign
here but if we were to write like this
then
the the physical or the geometrical
interpretation would have been
that this stress component would have
been directed in the positive
direction too okay so uh
that that is
wrong so because that is wrong this is
also wrong
so this should be actually in the
negative direction
then you have in total from here sigma
1 2 with no negative sign and this is
that sigma 1 2
okay
and finally
you try to think what about the sigma 1
3
so the sigma 1 3
no problem with the positivity
convention so
that sigma 1 3 can be written correctly
only if you
draw it in the negative 3 direction
because you understand
the 1 is actually being contributed from
the minus 1 direction
so it should be the 3 should be actually
in the minus 3 direction
it should be like sigma 1 3 okay
you see on this plane where the unit
outward normal
is along the positive one direction
the sense of the stress components
this one sigma one two it is oriented
along the positive
two direction and this one is oriented
along the positive three direction
but for this plane where the unit
outward normal is along the negative one
direction
the stress component sigma one two that
is oriented along the negative of the
two direction and the sigma one three is
oriented along the negative of the three
direction and this
has a direct connection with what you
studied in your first year
so back then you were not considering
mostly
uh so you were mostly considering the
two dimensional pictures
and there you wrote things like this
that
sigma xx and
this one as tau xy
this one you wrote as sigma xx again
and this one was your tau xy
this was your sigma yy
and this was your tau yx
this was your yx
sorry
and this one was your sigma yy now if
you just imagine that that your x is
like 1
and your y is like 2 can you not see the
similarity between this two dimensional
picture
and this three dimensional picture this
basically the same thing
there in your first year you just
studied the two-dimensional version
now you are studying the
three-dimensional version that's all
there is to it
okay so uh
in the in the next part of the lecture
what we'll do is
we'll consider uh the question about the
symmetricity which i alluded to
in the last part of our lecture so we'll
see that sigma transpose is equal to
sigma
itself so the sigma the stress tensor is
going to be symmetric
uh for the most common applications we
are going to consider
there will there are special cases where
it is not symmetric but
for our course we are not going to
consider that and then we will see how
this can be
finally utilized if we go back to the
to the this balance of linear momentum
equation
to formulate an equation which is not
involving these integrations
okay so that is the plan for the
next uh part of our lecture so uh
thank you very much uh we'll meet again
in the next part